AARON ZEMACH: Hey guys,
thanks for coming out.
So to get started before
we talk about the museum,
I'm interested if you could
just talk a little bit about how
the two of you first met each
other, got to know each other.
What's the story of you two?
MATT HARKINS: Oh,
we met at a party.
We both had done comedy
at the UC [INAUDIBLE].
It's like an improv in the city.
And they have every year
a New Year's Eve party
at a terrible bar, and
so we both were there
at not having fun.
And then we just said
hi, I guess, but then we
didn't see each other for
like a year afterwards.
We got donuts once in between.
VIVIANA OLEN: Yeah,
I kept on trying
to make him a best
friend, and I knew
that that was going to happen
but he was avoiding it.
And then I started asking
where's Matt Harkins.
And he came over
to film this web
series I was doing
with my roommate's cats
called "TheatriCats,"
which is a play
and how the cats acted out.
And he came over and we
just had so much fun,
and then started hanging out
every day and working together
and stuff.
And then a few months
later we moved in together.
AARON ZEMACH: Awesome, cool.
So you moved in
together, were roommates,
and then one night you decide
to watch the film on Netflix
"The Price of Gold."
MATT HARKINS: Yes.
AARON ZEMACH: And
could you quickly
for those of us who
maybe have forgotten
a little bit of the details
of what that movie recounts
give a brief overview of the
story of "Price of Gold."
MATT HARKINS: So fun, there's a
"30 for 30" series on Netflix.
You can watch it, it's ESPN.
And there all
these documentaries
about sports, but this one was
about Tonya Harding and Nancy
Kerrigan, because
I wouldn't have
watched any of the other ones.
They're all like-- the
other ones are good.
It's like Denis Leary
talking about baseball.
But this one I just
started watching
and then immediately
started texting Viviana.
VIVIANA OLEN: You
told me to come home
and that we had to
watch it together.
MATT HARKINS: It's so good.
So the story is basically, it
just goes through the events
in 1994 focusing on
that, but really focuses
on Tonya Harding,
because it was made right
around the 20th anniversary.
So they had two
different documentaries.
One of them Nancy and Tonya did.
That was the NBC one because NBC
offered Nancy the opportunity
to be a commenter
on the Olympics.
This one she kept saying
maybe she'd do but then she
eventually didn't.
So they really just
focused on Tonya
and that's what got
us so passionate,
because we do feel
she's an American hero.
VIVIANA OLEN: Because you
remember the story at all,
you just kind of remember
the parody of Tonya Harding,
and how you think
of the sex tape and
you think of just "Mad
TV" version of it.
And then you watch
the documentary
and it's like just this
woman who came from nothing.
All she really had
was ice skating
and she makes it to
the pinnacle of that.
She makes it to
the Olympics twice.
And she's the first American,
not just the first woman,
but the first American
to land the triple axel.
These are all things that
we had never ever, ever
heard about because we were like
six or seven when it happened.
And then to see her,
she was like she
made a few bad choices, she
was around the wrong people.
And she comes from nothing,
she reaches the pinnacle
and then she just
loses everything,
and then it's fascinating.
And we were so excited
about talking about it
and nobody else had
also just seen it,
so that's kind of how we
ended up making a museum.
AARON ZEMACH: All right,
really quickly just the facts
so we can all recall, 1994
Olympics, the qualifications.
Instead of me just saying
it and you confirming it,
maybe it's better if
you just lay this out,
because your knowledge is
a bit better than mine.
MATT HARKINS: So
yeah, Tonya Harding,
she was the first American to
land a triple axel in 1991.
And then at the same time
Nancy, both her and Nancy
were showing up in competitions.
And then fast forward a few
years later, they're 24 and 25,
so this is really the
last year that they're
going to be able to compete.
And right before the
qualifying championships
for competing in the
Olympics, Nancy Kerrigan
is attacked at the arena
where everyone's practicing.
And at first they have
no clue who did this.
But really quickly it
becomes pretty evident
that Tonya Harding's husband
was definitely involved,
and then the suspicion is then
that Tonya Harding was involved
in planning the attack itself.
VIVIANA OLEN: Yeah, then
a media frenzy followed,
and this is right before
the O.J. Simpson thing,
so it was like months of just
every day the story changed
and it just kind of took over.
AARON ZEMACH: Cool, so I do
want to talk about the media
reaction, but before that you
guys saw this documentary.
You really enjoyed
it, you thought
there was a story that
was worth telling.
I feel like a lot of
people watch documentaries
and have similar reactions.
Very few of them decide
to take that and then
go build a museum
in their apartment
based on the documentary.
MATT HARKINS: Yeah.
VIVIANA OLEN: Mhm.
AARON ZEMACH: So how did
that idea come about?
VIVIANA OLEN:
Well, the apartment
we moved-- we moved in
there a month before,
and it was the first place
we looked at because it had
two rooms away from each other.
And it didn't have
a living room but it
had a really long
hallway and we're like,
oh we'll do something with this.
And then he was working
at a museum at the time,
and he-- there was
actually a text exchange.
He was like nobody
at the museum wants
to talk about Tonya
and Nancy, and I
said ha, ha, ha you're making
it the Tonya and Nancy Museum.
And then like I think
like 4 AM the next day,
I was like Matt, Matt we're
going to make the Tonya
and Nancy Museum.
That's exactly how it happened.
AARON ZEMACH: And when you at
that early stage when you're
thinking we're going
to start a museum,
did you have any sense of what
it would mean to you to form
a museum, the type
of things you would
be looking for to have in it.
VIVIANA OLEN: The original
plan, the original Kickstarter
we were asking for $75 to
blow up pictures and put them
in the hallway, and we
figured that would be enough.
And it was like oh this
will be a fun, funny thing.
You'll come over and you'll
walk down this dark hallway
and see pictures of Tonya
and Nancy, and it's crazy.
And then we launched
the Kickstarter
and then I mean we didn't
really think ahead of time,
oh there is a figure
skating community.
But I mean of course there's
a figure skating community
and they started
reaching out to us.
And the first person we
met that really took it
from joke to like, oh this
is going to change everything
was Lois Elfman who was a figure
skating reporter, journalist.
And she contacted us
right away and was
like I have artifacts for you.
And so we met with her and she
gave us all this amazing stuff
that she'd had in
her house like--
MATT HARKINS: A book, a scoring
book from 1990 with Nancy
and Tonya's face
on the same page.
Then she gave us backstage
passes that she had
for different championships.
VIVIANA OLEN: Of the one where
the attack happened as well.
MATT HARKINS: Yeah,
there was one,
there was a ticket for the Joe
Louis COBO Arena in Detroit.
VIVIANA OLEN: Original
pictures of Nancy Kerrigan
that she took, and then this
one pin from that championship.
And she was just like, it
was so important to her
and she gave it to us.
And then we got home and we're
like, OK we have to really try,
and so we went to Michaels
and got so many shadow boxes.
And then more-- and then
people started making art
and people started
sending us other things.
And so we kind of just came
up with this hub for it.
I mean, so it did
start as like a joke,
but we put so many hours
and so much love into it,
and we're just so committed to
it that it's very real to us.
AARON ZEMACH: You
know one of the--
so I've been to the
museum at their apartment.
And one of the other interesting
things I think you do
is you really follow not only
the events of the incident
but also how the media talked
about the incident afterwards.
It's not only
documenting the skaters
but it's documenting
how we as a nation kind
of responded to the skaters.
MATT HARKINS: Yeah, the thing is
that's like the craziest thing.
I feel like especially
with Tonya Harding
it's amazing that she
didn't kill anyone,
because the things that she
had to go through are insane.
And if it was me, I would've--
first off I wouldn't have even,
I would be in a
basement somewhere.
But she came from just a
terrible upbringing and then
from there achieved so much.
But then also once
it starts coming out
that she might be
involved there's
so much press thrown her way.
And at first when
you watch it she
seems excited because it
was one of the big things
that she had to go through
was seeing how unfair it was
that other figure skaters
who kind of were more
in line with what people
thought figure skaters should be
would get endorsement
deals that she just
wouldn't get, despite the
fact that she was so talented.
So when she first gets this
attention she's excited,
but then it's obviously
not good attention
and it just builds and
it builds to the point
where people are getting her
truck towed so that she'll
run outside and they can
attack her with questions,
just swarm her, basically.
And she also has
no team around her.
Nancy has a full
staff basically,
agents coaches, people were
just pulling back from Tonya
so she's doing
this all on her own
and still gets herself
to the Olympics.
But it's that moment that
was the thing that we relate
to the most, which was at the
Olympics there's just the total
meltdown because she's--
it's her second program.
She's planning on doing a triple
Axel, which she hadn't been
able to do since
early in the '90s,
but it was her way of sort
of saying OK, well this
will make them forget all
that other stuff that people
are talking about.
And then halfway
through her program
she stops because
she messes up a jump.
She had a problem
with her laces before.
She showed up late, so it's
just watching it all crash.
VIVIANA OLEN: And
all of those events,
it feels kind of like
the birth of reality TV
because that
performance is still
one of the seven most watched
things live still to this day.
MATT HARKINS: [INAUDIBLE], yeah.
VIVIANA OLEN: Yeah,
and so it's like--
and then every day you
just had these two women
and every day you were following
just every little thing
they were doing and just
impressing so much on it.
So it just, it feels like it was
foreshadowing so much of today.
MATT HARKINS: And they
made them into these--
I don't know what the word is,
but it was just like Nancy was
very much the ice queen and then
Tonya was just like the trash,
and that was how they
were constantly presented.
And it's just not
true, but it was--
VIVIANA OLEN: And
that's what we try
to do as much as
possible with the museum
is cut away from that and
talk about them as athletes,
and we try to show
them at their best.
Yeah, separate them as much
as possible from the media
storm, because there would
have been nothing new to say
if we were just kind
of going off of--
but that's all inspired
by the documentary, too.
It's so good, and we got to
meet the director of that.
So that was very
cool, she came by.
But yeah, so it's just, it's
really she told the story best
and then we're just
mimicking the movie.
MATT HARKINS: Yeah,
all we're doing
is making sure we keep
having the conversation
that we wanted to have with a
bunch of people all the time
but nobody was ready.
So anybody who comes over
it's like fun and everything
but then we get
to talk about what
we wanted to talk about to
begin with, which was just how--
VIVIANA OLEN: Good
this movie is.
MATT HARKINS: --good
AARON ZEMACH: So you guys do
have this interesting aspect
of your museum
where-- so in order
to view the museum
people send you an email,
and you respond and set up a
time with them to come visit.
And then you're essentially
welcoming these strangers
into your apartment
to view the museum.
What was that like
to make the decision
to just sort of open the
doors to whoever can send you
an email?
VIVIANA OLEN: I think
it was just like, oh
well first we were like
we'll meet people downstairs.
That seemed to us like
some amazing safeguard,
like that we meet them on
the corner by the bodega.
If they're crazy we
just won't have them up.
A few problems with
that, we got so lazy
and stopped meeting people
downstairs because actually
we're just like come up.
So many people have
our buzzer code.
And the second part
is you go downstairs,
you meet somebody who
is creepy and we do not
have it in us to say no
you can't come upstairs.
So we have let some weird people
inside, but nobody has hurt us.
I think it takes the appeal
out of it for serial killers
or something because we're
going to be such easy prey.
MATT HARKINS: Yeah,
they like the chase.
VIVIANA OLEN: But honestly,
anybody who's interested in it
are people like us.
That's really who
we've met, people
who like figure skating
documentaries and people who
like kitsch and camp.
So it's been so, so fun.
MATT HARKINS: The
other most fun part
I think has just been seeing how
people approach that, like just
seeing who shows up late, who
inside the apartment-- which
one time there was a
huge group of people
and they then invited
their friends over.
VIVIANA OLEN: Oh,
that was terrible.
MATT HARKINS: And then
their friends came--
VIVIANA OLEN: And they invited
someone else, too, I think.
MATT HARKINS: Yeah,
yeah, yeah some guy.
VIVIANA OLEN: There
was like three people.
MATT HARKINS: And the guy didn't
talk at all, which is fine,
but she kept going around.
This is a very small apartment.
VIVIANA OLEN: Very small
MATT HARKINS: It's like yeah,
you're in our apartment,
whatever.
But also she kept
going into our bedrooms
to like look around and peek.
It's like, you can't
do, that's not right.
VIVIANA OLEN: We did
not say anything though.
We also don't like
confrontations.
MATT HARKINS: Oh yeah, no.
VIVIANA OLEN: So this is not
a thing to set up for us but--
AARON ZEMACH: Yeah,
yeah, and there
is sort of this new movement,
especially in New York
of the micro museum.
So there is like the
Museum of Morbid Anatomy
and a museum I've heard
about in Chinatown,
a museum in an elevator.
Have you guys been in
touch with other people
involved in a sort of this
micro museum movement?
MATT HARKINS: Not so much.
We reached out to a bunch of
different museums a while ago,
just about when we
didn't know what
would happen with the
collection that we have.
And the response
was not [INAUDIBLE].
VIVIANA OLEN: I'm
not super respected
in the museum community.
Yeah but it's fun seeing
those other things pop up.
And I think we didn't
know this at the time
but there was also
in the '90s there
was a troll museum in some
woman's apartment in the Lower
East Side.
I think it's-- I mean
it's so appealing
because there's the idea of
like the Route 66 Museum where
it's like the Museum of
Spoons and that's so fun,
so it's nice to see it
coming back a little bit.
AARON ZEMACH: And you guys have
got quite the variety of press
for the museum.
You've been featured
on TV, and radio,
and in magazines we
were just talking about.
What do you think it is
about the museum that
captures people's interest
in that kind of way?
VIVIANA OLEN: I think the first
round definitely just talking
about Tonya and Nancy again,
because it instantly-- you
remember where you were,
how you remember it.
And then I think also the
fact that it was in a hallway
was appealing, because people
like to go into other people's
houses if they can.
MATT HARKINS: There's
some museum in France
that's-- it's like an old house
and it's run by a guy who lives
there.
And you book an appointment,
and you go to see the house
and he just walks around with
his shirt off in the background
and makes eggs.
And it's like people
go because they
would get the story of
like oh, he's so weird.
So I feel like that's
also a thing that people--
VIVIANA OLEN: Yeah, I think
a lot of people come just
to see the freaks.
MATT HARKINS: Yeah, kind
of a little like that.
Yeah, and it really does
feel like we're freaks
when it's just one of us.
If it's both of us
together it's fun,
because it's sort of like
we'll play off each other
or whatever.
But if it's just one of us,
especially if it's one of us
and then a couple on a
date, it's like all right.
Very creepy.
AARON ZEMACH: The third
wheel museum curator.
VIVIANA OLEN: Yeah.
MATT HARKINS: Yeah, there
was one time it was these two
people and it just really
seemed like they just wanted
to hang out in there alone.
So I kind of backed off and
then there's nowhere for me.
I'm not going to lie down.
We don't have like a--
VIVIANA OLEN: We don't
have a couch or anything.
MATT HARKINS: Yeah,
there's no couch.
So I just kind of sat and then
just kept peeking my head in.
And I was like, you doing OK?
And they were just
like, yeah, we're fine.
And then they left.
AARON ZEMACH: So
Googlers as a bunch,
we're pretty creative people.
If anyone here was interested
in starting their own museum
about a certain topic
in their apartment
or some other small
museum, do you
have advice about
what to do to start
that, what to do to make that
successful for someone else?
VIVIANA OLEN: Definitely
eBay is great.
MATT HARKINS: Oh, eBay is great.
VIVIANA OLEN: Because you
can just get a lot of stuff
on there.
MATT HARKINS: And it's
so cheap it's shocking.
It's honestly insane how cheap
some of these things are.
You can get a magazine--
and I just look,
there's magazines that
have O.J. On the cover
and they're like, they're $3.
I don't know why,
for me it seems
like that should be a lot of
money, but they're very cheap.
And then they have these
Nancy Kerrigan trading cards,
which were still pretty cheap.
They were like $30 and they
don't make them anymore.
VIVIANA OLEN: Yeah,
those are artifacts.
MATT HARKINS: That's it, and
so we've been giving them away
to the people who come.
But there's so
much stuff on eBay.
Oh, I just saw this also
because I was actually
just looking for O.J. themed
stuff because that show is on.
But they have a juror pin,
it says like designated TV
juror, which is so creepy
and that's for sale on eBay
for like $2 if you
want it, and maybe not.
VIVIANA OLEN: So go for it.
But I think the big
thing is like-- I
mean you know there's the
internet, as you know.
So it's so easy to
connect with people
who are interested in
what you're interested in.
And that's really
why this was so fun
and I think caught
on a little bit,
because we just connect
with other people who
liked the idea.
And then they've
come from all over.
We've met people from
Australia and we're in contact
with the guy who runs
the Tonya Harding fan
club in New Zealand.
His name is Terry.
He is very dedicated.
And it's just all these
people that in another time
we would not know existed,
and so it's been great.
AARON ZEMACH:
Great, and you guys
are working now on a
follow-up or a special exhibit
from the Tonya Harding
Nancy Kerrigan Museum.
Could you explain
to everyone what
that is that you're working on?
VIVIANA OLEN: Gets
me very excited.
One of the artists
who had made us
a drawing for the permanent
collection, Laura Collins,
she lives in Chicago.
And she has a series called
the "Olsen Twins Hiding
from Paparazzi" of paintings.
And they're hiding
behind Birkin bags,
and Starbucks cups,
and BlackBerrys, so we
want to bring that here.
It's very jarring
to see a whole wall
of women hiding
their face from you,
which is very creepy and fun.
And we're going to have
special installations
inside the museum, like a
selfie station where you can
hide behind a giant BlackBerry.
MATT HARKINS: Yeah, we
made a giant BlackBerry.
It's to scale, and all of the
shift keys do what they would.
It doesn't turn on but it
looks the way it should.
So you can hide behind it.
We just want it to be
interactive, and also
have fun with nostalgia in
general, because there's
so much of it now.
And I feel like it
is always creepy
when people post a
GIF of the Olsen twins
saying some famous line,
because it's always like to me
at least that is just a
child who some adult yelled
at for 20 minutes before
and he's like you say this
and you say it right.
And then it's like,
everyone's like, fuck you.
So I feel like this is a fun
way to go like another step
forward.
It's like yeah, if we're into
being nostalgic about this,
here's how creepy it can be.
AARON ZEMACH: Yeah,
I feel like it also
continues that conversation.
You talked about the
beginnings of reality TV, sort
of early '90s as
the Olsen twins also
became a part of the
media narrative as well.
VIVIANA OLEN: Yeah, it
definitely carries that on.
When I was a kid I was a big
Mary-Kate and Ashley fan,
and I went to this theme park
to meet Mary-Kate and Ashley.
And you wait in line
for like three hours
and it just got more and
more depressing and weird.
And then you pass by them and
they're just sitting there
and they're both like this.
And I was just like, oh I'm
so sorry for looking at you,
and they grew up in that.
And then the second
they really hit 18,
they just went into hiding,
which is just so cool I think.
And I feel like
they did their work.
And still they
can't walk around,
they can't walk down the street.
And so yeah, just
highlighting that but in a fun
way with a giant BlackBerry.
MATT HARKINS: And
we'll also have
a model of a table at
Mary-Kate's wedding.
Because there was when she
got married on Black Friday
last year, there was an article
in like two places about how
she had bowls and
bowls of cigarettes
at each table,
which was very fun.
VIVIANA OLEN: It drew
us in immediately
and we said that is glamorous.
MATT HARKINS: Because
there's no photos.
Everyone had to turn
their phones in.
The only story is just
that it was so smoky inside
and you couldn't see anything.
So we'll have a table like that.
We have a model of it now with
teeny tiny cigarettes that I
spent too much time making.
AARON ZEMACH: And
you guys are still
looking for some art
patrons for your Kickstarter
that's going on right
now to finish that up.
VIVIANA OLEN: Yes,
our Kickstarter
is running until Sunday at 7:00.
And we're asking
for more than $75
this time, because we
want to rent a storefront
and do a lot of cultural events,
and then ship the art here.
That's very
expensive apparently,
but it'll be really
fun if we get to do it.
Check that out.
MATT HARKINS: Yeah,
it's also we've
met so many people with our
last project that this one,
it's so cool to kind of try and
continue those relationships.
At the last minute
we had a museum gala
for our Tonya Harding Museum.
And Viviana's sister was in
town and she found on Groupon
a guy who would make cupcakes
and did a deal for us
to bring cupcakes there,
and they were so good.
So he is going to have a pop-up
shop in the pop-up gallery
with cupcakes with
all of the art on it.
VIVIANA OLEN: And we've
gotten submissions already.
This guy did this painting
of the Olsen twins hiding
from dinosaurs
instead of paparazzi.
So it's really fun to see what
people come up with and just--
it's just a way to say hey,
let's make some more art
and put it together,
and that kind of stuff.
AARON ZEMACH: Do you
guys feel like there
is enough pop culture,
interesting topics in your life
that this is something you
can see yourselves continuing
to do?
VIVIANA OLEN: Yeah.
MATT HARKINS: Yeah, I
mean it's definitely--
I think it's just trying
to find other people who
maybe are as passionate.
VIVIANA OLEN: I think there's
a million things though.
I would see like an SVU exhibit
and that could be very fun.
Just a lot of pictures
of Ice-T. I love that.
MATT HARKINS: And there's so
much good fan art online and--
VIVIANA OLEN: People
make beautiful fan art.
MATT HARKINS: Oh, they make
such beautiful fan art.
And a lot of times
it's a joke, but it's
like they have created
something that is so good.
VIVIANA OLEN: Beautiful.
MATT HARKINS: And
it's about everything.
HGTV shows, there's fan art.
There's fan fiction too.
If you've watched
"Love it or List it."
Yeah, it's a great show.
And they have these two
hosts, Hilary and David,
and they have great chemistry.
I sound very old
but I love them.
And there's a fan
fiction about them.
Nothing happens but
it's just about--
VIVIANA OLEN: Erotic fan fiction
is what he's talking about.
AARON ZEMACH: Oh jeez.
So we have a microphone
down in the second row
if anyone has any
questions they'd
like to ask Matt and
Viviana about the museum,
or the skaters, or
anything at all.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
VIVIANA OLEN: Hi.
AUDIENCE: So what is
your favorite artifact
that you've collected if
you had to choose one?
VIVIANA OLEN: I think
definitely-- well,
my favorite piece
of art is there
are these two cross
stitches of Tonya and Nancy,
and they're kind of
facing each other.
And their shading
on them is insane.
They're so beautiful.
As far as artifacts,
what do you think?
MATT HARKINS: I mean
I like the magazine.
There's a "National
Enquirer" magazine
we got off of eBay
because it's just
I think a lot of times
people would sort of say,
how much do you think
has changed since 1994.
But then if you look at
one of these magazines
like absolutely nothing.
They're all the
same, and they're
great because they're just
about different famous people.
And there's like, especially
the "National Enquirer"
they have a life savers section.
There is an article that Sharon
Stone saving a choking victim.
But if you look at that, they're
no different than any website
that's around now.
It's just if it
happened today I think
there'd be a much more--
there'd be like Twitter,
there'd be any sort
of social media
where people could say
hey, let's maybe not
look at it this way.
And I think there would
be more I guess just more
outlooks on something.
Because it is very, when you
look at the magazines which
were really the place
people were going,
it's just insane how sexist,
how stupid some of these
spins on the story were.
AUDIENCE: Hello, so I have a
bunch of questions I could ask
but I'll keep it
to the good ones.
I noticed on the
Kickstarter page
that you mentioned
something about
like an ongoing investigation
of the way women
are portrayed in the media,
which you just kind of alluded
to.
So it's interesting because
I think to a casual observer,
there's a certain it seems like
a very almost kitschy attitude,
but there is also a relatively
serious and important critical
attitude that now these
two exhibits are taking on.
So do you think that it
would be dangerous to push it
more in that serious
direction in terms
of how you market it, or
is that part of what you're
trying to do?
VIVIANA OLEN: I think that
is not for us to talk about.
We're going to bring the kitsch.
And we think that's
a conversation
other people should have.
AUDIENCE: Let the think
piecers think piece.
VIVIANA OLEN: But we
definitely aren't smart enough
to sound smart about it.
AUDIENCE: Oh, I don't
know if that's true.
VIVIANA OLEN: Well
we-- but yeah.
No, I mean I think like
the idea of Tonya and Nancy
just being obliterated
by the media
and it just ruined their
lives in so many ways.
And same thing with
the Olsen twins.
We want to bring the
fun aspect of it,
and we definitely hope it gets
people talking and thinking
about the seriousness
of it, because it
is so jarring to celebrate
or have fun in that.
MATT HARKINS: Yeah, that's
basically the conversation
we had at first.
When we first watched
the documentary,
all we wanted to talk about was
how awful America treated Tonya
Harding.
But at the same
time, it's like, it's
kind of like it is
ridiculous to be just sitting
around and forcing people
to talk about this in we're
in the year 2016 or whatever.
So it's just that mix of
both I guess, but that's
the fun of it is like--
and there's so much of it
happening now,
even the O.J. show.
I keep calling it the O.J. show.
That's like the whole thing,
and I just read some interview
with Marsha Clark
and it was insane how
she was picking her
words so carefully
because of everything she
had been through in the '90s.
And I think it's fun.
It's fun to look back.
AUDIENCE: It's now getting the
Paulson treatment, [INAUDIBLE]
Paulson.
MATT HARKINS: Yeah, yeah.
VIVIANA OLEN: Have you watched
the Monica Lewinsky "TED Talk."
MATT HARKINS: Oh,
that's so good.
VIVIANA OLEN: It's
so crazy because she
is so careful about
every word she says,
because she was
bullied so, so hard
and she's had to go in
hiding for a long time.
And now she's back and
she's just like every breath
is practiced because it could
just blow up in your face
again.
It's just it's crazy.
AUDIENCE: It is.
So second follow-up
question before I pass it
to somebody else.
You mentioned fan art
and I hadn't really
thought about that as
being the thread that
goes through both
of these things,
although it's pretty obvious.
I'm an idiot.
But why isn't there
a museum of fan art?
VIVIANA OLEN: Right.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I was
like people would probably
pay you to exhibit
there, so it could-- it
seems like it could be a pretty
good money-making opportunity.
VIVIANA OLEN: That's
something we've
thought about where it's if we
did have a storefront it could
just be fan art.
And how fun would that be?
AUDIENCE: So fun.
VIVIANA OLEN: Oh, so fun.
So give us a storefront
and we'll just do it.
MATT HARKINS: We
had a conversation
about that one night.
And there's some case,
it's Cheryl Tiegs
versus some artist.
And it's about fan art.
It relates about the
selling about fan art.
I could be way off.
AUDIENCE: You guys should get
in touch with Richard Prince.
I feel like he'd probably be
down to go in on this with you,
because he loves
getting sued and yeah,
so reach out to Richard.
VIVIANA OLEN: Yeah, we
haven't been sued yet
and we feel like--
MATT HARKINS: Yeah, but
a couple people have let
us know that they could but--
VIVIANA OLEN: Yeah, two people
said I could sue you but I
won't.
AARON ZEMACH: Yeah,
I guess while we're
waiting for more
questions, have you
guys had any sort of
contact with Nancy's people,
with Tonya's people?
VIVIANA OLEN: Nancy's
agency came by,
this woman who worked there.
And we were so
scared when she was
coming, because we were like
she's going to just have
a letter that tells us to stop.
And I was like, I'll rip
everything down, I'm sorry.
But she was so nice and great.
And she said that
Nancy's agent, who
is also her husband, they run
an agency together in Boston.
And she brought
us a lot of like--
she brought us a signed
head shot and then--
MATT HARKINS: A CD.
VIVIANA OLEN: --a CD of
Nancy's only song she recorded.
It's very housewives,
it's very fun.
MATT HARKINS: "Love
Come Shining Through."
VIVIANA OLEN: It's called
"Love Come Shining Through."
We listen to it a lot, and
then a Halloween on ice DVD.
And they were really
positive, they
were just like it's
absurd but fun.
And then Tonya we did hear
from her through Terry
in New Zealand who said that
her godmother slash manager said
it's cool but she's
too busy to come,
which is all we could ask for.
We just don't want
to make anybody mad.
AARON ZEMACH: Good questions.
VIVIANA OLEN: Come
by to the museum.
It's fun.
MATT HARKINS: Yeah, just email.
AARON ZEMACH: Yeah, so if
people who saw this talk now
or who are watching
online later are
super excited to come see the
museum, what should they do?
What do they do?
VIVIANA OLEN: Oh, just
email us, or tweet at us,
or go to our website thandk1994
and there's a contact form
there.
And yeah we're around
most of the time.
Just email as and come on by.
MATT HARKINS: And
we'll make it happen.
There may be a chain
of like 20 emails,
but we'll make it happen.
VIVIANA OLEN: Yeah.
AARON ZEMACH: All
right, awesome.
So if there aren't
any more questions
let's thank Matt and
Viviana for coming and--
VIVIANA OLEN: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
AARON ZEMACH: Thanks so
much guys. much, guys.
VIVIANA OLEN: Thank you.
MATT HARKINS: Thank you.